deux cent seize médecins dénonce la
torture subie par julian assange ils ont
publié une lettre jeudi dans la revue
scientifique the lancet est un document
dans lequel ils alertent sur l'état de
santé du cofondateur de wikileaks menacé
d'extradition vers les états unis pour
avoir mon leur appel publié des
documents secrets en 2010 le groupe de
médecins estiment qu'ils courent un
risque important de contracter le
coronavirus et d'ici qu'on ait dû
succomber
julian assange est incarcéré près de
londres lundi dans la capitale
britannique aura lieu une audience
administrative dans le cadre de la
procédure d'extradition vers les états
unis du lanceur d'alerté il a été
cantonné à un box en vitre pare-balles
d'où il eût été impossible de suivre
l'audience
on lui a refusé de s'entretenir avec ses
avocats il a été fouillé à nu menotté 11
fois déplacé dans onze cellules
différentes et certains documents
confidentiels de sa défense ont été
saisis l'isolation et une stimulation
insuffisantes sont des techniques de
torture grave capable de provoquer un
désespoir important de la désorientation
la déstabilisation et la désintégration
de fonctions mentales et psychologiques
crucial mais on continue de parler de la
situation de julian assange avec
stéphanie gibeau auteur du livre la
traque des lanceurs d'alert bonjour
stéphanie gibeau merci d'être avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france alors la
première question tout simplement que
savons-nous de l'état de santé actuel de
doubler un songe pas vous voyez on peut
nous faire confiance à ces médecins et
aux avocats de tulle naissance qui
justement ne font que répéter qu' il
subit une torture psychologique est le
fait de publier ce type de pétitions au
sein du land set ça montre que justement
son état de santé est catastrophique on
peut rappeler aussi que des journalistes
étaient mobilisés et avaient déjà fait
une pétition à ce sujet des avocats
également que la communauté médicale
international prend la décision de
publier au niveau de danger en fait sur
la vie des humains sens c'est
qu'effectivement ça commence à être très
très grave et très préoccupant alors
cela fait déjà plusieurs mois qu'il
existe de vives inquiétudes au sujet de
julian assange est ce que quelque chose
a été fait pour améliorer justement ses
conditions de détention mais écoutez
c'était le but de votre reportage à
l'instant a priori non c'est justement
une situation de pression psychologique
et de droits qui ne sont pas respectées
puisque on peut rappeler que c'est le
seul prisonnier politique en europe qui
n'a commis aucun crime
à part faire son métier à part publier
des informations qui ont été vérifiés
dont on connaît l'origine et et il n'y a
absolument aucun aucun délit donc il ya
vrai il ya véritablement à la fois un
problème de droits de l'homme qui a été
rapporté par le rapporteur des nations
unies spécialisée sur les droits de
l'homme est là et la torture où tous les
hommes politiques britanniques à
commencer par boris johnson disent être
impuissant sur le dossier parce qu'ils
ne trouvent pas se positionner sur un
cas particulier la reine élisabeth
reconnu elisabeth avait dit que c'était
un problème politique qu'elle ne pouvait
rien faire non plus donc qui peut faire
quelque chose si ce qui règne et ceux
qui dirigent ne peuvent rien faire
ça me rappelle quelque part aussi mon
dossier en france où michel sapin le
ministre des finances en poste qui
pourrait qu'ils pouvaient rien faire sur
mon dossier donc on est sur un véritable
problème de droits de l'homme au coeur
de
l'europe dans un des pays du g7 où la
torture
finalement passe sous les radars du tout
le monde politique c'est très inquiétant
alors où en est-on exactement du
feuilleton judiciaire autour de julian
assange quelles vont être les prochaines
étapes pour lui l'écouté il ya déjà des
audiences qui ont lieu régulièrement au
sujet justement de l'extradition
potentiels vers les états unis
c'est pour ça qu'on on aimerait bien
aussi entendre la voix la voix
américaine savoir où on en est ces
paroles qui ont été prononcées en disant
que tu la sens risquait cent soixante
quinze années de prison pour avoir
publié ces informations ce qu'est ce qui
est complètement choquant merci beaucoup
stéphanie gibeau d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin sur rtl france je rappelle que
vous êtes l'auteur du livre la traque
des lanceurs d'alert merci beaucoup